on X the other day. I felt as if I was
in a time warp. David Wood and I have
often discussed the fact that Islamic
doctrines that Islamic apologists used
to deny, now they readily avow that
Islam does really teach these things.
And so things that we were called liars
for saying years ago, such that Muhammad
married a little girl and so on,
nowadays Muslims say yes, he did and
we're proud of it. And yet the other day
it was as if nothing had happened and we
were back in 2005
because a Muslim posted on X, Islam
commands to kill non-Muslim.
[Laughter]
And so I thought, well, he's scorning
the idea that Islam commands to kill
non-Muslims. Maybe we need a little
truth here. And I posted five Quran
verses where Islam commands the killing
of non-Muslims. Kill them wherever you
find them which is found at Quran
chapter 2 1914
89 and 491.
Kill the idolattors wherever you find
them which is found at Quran 9:5. And
when when you meet the unbelievers,
strike necks. Quran 47:4.
Well, this went viral. Last I saw, there
were a million and a half views on it
and hundreds hundreds maybe thousands of
furious angry replies from Muslims
saying I was lying. Which is interesting
because you know quoting the Quran now
in ways that they find unflattering is
lying and above all saying I was taking
it out of context
and why didn't I provide the full
context and I thought wow I haven't
heard that one in years. I used to hear
it all the time in the early days in the
1990s and then right after 911 when I'd
be speaking about Islam somewhere people
would constantly say, "Oh, you're taking
this out of context." But nowadays, just
as they readily avow child marriage,
Muslims have gotten into the habit, many
Islamic apologists that is, of saying,
"Sure, yes, we uh are all about warfare
and we're going to take over and like
Ali Dawa says, we'll I'm going to we'll
go doortodoor and kill the ex-Muslims."
And uh we're proud of that.
So it seems as if a lot of Muslims on X
did not get the memo and they're still
in the oh no Islam is peace and you're
taking it out of context mode. So even
though many of you may be familiar with
this material I think obviously there
are many who are not and let's put it
out on the record once again the context
of the killing verses in the Quran. Does
the Quran really teach that Muslims
should kill non-Muslims? So the first
verse that I quoted was chapter 2 verse
191. And uh another one of the things
that many people said was you should
give the verse right before and the
verse right after. So here's the whole
passage chapter 2 190 to 193. Fight for
the sake of Allah against those who
fight against you. But do not transgress
limits. Indeed Allah does not love
transgressors. and kill them wherever
you find them and drive them out from
where they drove you out. For
persecution is worse than slaughter. And
do not fight with them at the sacred
mosque until they first attack you
there. But if they attack you, then kill
them. This is the reward of unbelievers.
But if they stop, then indeed Allah is
forgiving, merciful, and fight them
until persecution is no more and
religion is for Allah. But if they stop
then let there be no hostility except
against wrongdoers.
All right. Now we need context right? So
let's look at Azbaban Nazul the classic
work of the Islamic scholar Alwahidi
giving the circumstances of revelation.
That is Azbabanul
the
times in which the verses of the Quran
were supposedly revealed to Muhammad.
And Alwahiti says these verses were
revealed concerning the treaty of Huda.
The messenger of Allah agreed to sign
this treaty. In the following year, the
messenger of Allah and his companions
got ready to perform the lesser
pilgrimage which they had missed. But at
the same time, they were afraid that
Kuresh would not honor their treaty, bar
them from the sacred house, and fight
them. The prophetic companions were
apprehensive of fighting them during the
sacred months and in the sacred
precinct. And so Allah revealed fight in
the way of Allah against those who fight
against you i.e. the kuresh.
So notice that Allah gives them this
revelation allowing them to fight the
kures not because the kuresh actually
broke the treaty but because Muhammad
and his companions were afraid they
would break it.
Now, nonetheless, this passage is often
invoked today to show that jihad can
only be defensive. And this is in part
based on a highly tendentious
translation. The words that I used in
the translation here from the critical
Quran, do not transgress are translated
by the famous Quran translator Muhammad
Marmaduk Pikthal as begin not
hostilities.
And Islamic apologists often invoke that
today to show that jihad can only be
defensive.
But this passage does not actually mean
that. The taps al jal one of the most
important commentaries on the Quran and
Sunni Islamic tradition says that this
verse was actually abregated by surah
talba that is surah nine which contains
numerous exhortations to jihad warfare
or by Allah's words and the following
ayat which is one of the Quran's
exhortations to kill them wherever you
find them. Iban Cathir, another classic
commentator on the Quran, does not agree
with Taps Al Jaline that this passage
was abregated. But he says that fight
them until persecution is no more and
religion is for Allah means that Muslims
must fight so that the religion of Allah
becomes dominant over all other
religions.
Iban Kathir also quotes the hadith in
which Muhammad says, "I am commanded to
fight with men till they testify that
there's no god but Allah and that
Muhammad is Allah's messenger. Observe
the prayer and pay the zakat. When they
do that, they will keep their lives and
their property safe from me except for
what is due to Islam and their reckoning
will be at Allah's hands." That's in
Bkari and Muslim multiple times as well
as in other hadith collections. That
particular version is in Mishkar Alam
Masabi number 12. Now this is clearly an
offensive fight. Muhammad's been
commanded to keep fighting until his
opponents become Muslim. So people who
are not fighting but are not Muslim must
be fought by the Muslims. Then when the
passage says but if they stop it is
saying if they become Muslim then don't
fight them. Not that Muslims must stop
fighting unbelievers if they stop
fighting them. This is clear also from
Muhammad's earliest biographer, the 8th
century Muslim known as Iban Ishak, who
explains the progression of Quranic
revelation about warfare. First, he
explains Allah allowed Muslims to wage
defensive warfare. But this was not
Allah's last word on the subject. He
then explains offensive jihad by
invoking a Quranic verse. Then Allah
sent down to him fight them so that
there be no more persecution
i.e until no believer is seduced from
his religion and religion is for Allah
that is until Allah alone is worshiped.
So that's exactly this same passage and
clearly Ibanis hawk has in mind
offensive jihad as the per the purpose
of the fighting is simply to oppose
people who believe differently.
The second and third passages that I
quoted were both from Quran 4:89-91,
which goes like this. They wish that you
would disbelieve even as they disbelieve
that you may be on the same level. So do
not choose friends with from them until
they migrate in the way of Allah. If
they turn back, then take them and kill
them wherever you find them. and choose
no friend or helper from among them
except those who seek refuge with a
people with whom you have a covenant or
come to you because their hearts forbid
them to make war on you or make war on
their own people. If Allah had willed,
he could have given them power over you
so that assuredly they would have fought
you. So if they remain aloof from you
and do not wage war against you and
offer you peace, Allah offers you no way
against them. You will find others who
want security from you and security from
their own people. As often as they are
returned to hostility, they are plunged
into it. If they do not keep aloof from
you or offer you peace or hold off their
hands, then take them and kill them
wherever you find them. Against such
people, we have given you clear
justification.
The taps align makes clear that this
command to remain at peace with some
unbelievers refers only to those who
submit to Islamic rules as demies. He
says if they keep away from you and do
not fight you offering a truce and
submit to you, Allah has not given you
any way against such people to seize and
kill them.
So they have to submit. So the purpose
of the fighting for the Muslims is to
kill the unbelievers or force them to
submit to the Muslims. The fourth
passage is Quran chapter 9 4-6.
Give news of a painful doom to those who
disbelieve except for those of the
idolattors with whom you have a treaty
and who have not been deficient toward
you nor have supported anyone against
you. Fulfill their treaty to them until
their turn. Indeed, Allah loves those
who keep their duty. Then when the
sacred months have passed, kill the
idolattors wherever you find them and
take them and besiege them and prepare
for them every ambush. But if they
repent and establish prayer and give
alms, then seek their way free. Indeed,
Allah is forgiving, merciful, and if any
one of the idolattors seeks your
protection, then protect him so that he
may hear the word of Allah, and
afterward bring him to his place of
safety. That is because they are a
people who do not know.
Now, chapter 9:5 is the notorious verse
of the sword. Kill the idolattors
wherever you find them and so on. In a
sermon in 2003, none other than Osama
bin Laden rejoiced over this verse and
said, "Praise be to Allah, who revealed
the verse of the sword to his servant
and messenger in order to establish
truth and abolish falsehood."
Iben Juzai, a 14th century Islamic
scholar, says that this verse abregates
every peace treaty in the Quran and
specifically abregates the Quran's
directive to set free or ransom captive
unbelievers. As chapter 47:4 directs,
according to Aiudi, another commentator
on the Quran, this is an ayat of the
sword which abregates pardon, truce, and
overlooking, that is overlooking the
pagans's offenses. The taps align says
that the Muslims must kill the
idolattors wherever you find them and
seize them by capture and besiege them
in citadels and fortresses until they
either fight or become Muslim.
So Iban Ca echoes this also directing
that Muslims should not wait until you
find them. Rather seek and besiege them
in their areas and forts. Gather
intelligence about them in the various
roads and fairways so that what is made
wide looks ever smaller to them. This
way they will have no choice but to die
or embrace Islam.
Many Islamic apologists say that this
passage refers only to warfare in the
seventh century. Now, that may fool some
people, but it raises the question of
why it's in the Quran at all, since the
Quran is supposed to be a book that's
valid for all time. None of these
Islamic authorities say anything about
restricting this passage to the seventh
century. On the contrary, Iban Cathir
says the unbelievers must be killed on
the earth in general except for the
sacred area that is the sacred mosque
which is traditionally understood as
being the mosque in Mecca. So this
implies an endless conflict.
The conflict ends when the unbelievers
become Muslim. As the passage says,
establish prayer or give alms. This is
what those are the pillars some of the
pillars of Islam. As for the part about
idolattors seeking protection, Iban
Cathir says that pagans are to be given
safe passage not on an indefinite basis
but so that they may learn about the
religion of Allah so that Allah's call
will spread among his servants.
The last passage I quoted was 474 which
is part of this passage. That is because
those who disbelieve follow falsehood
and because those who believe follow the
truth from their Lord. In this way,
Allah makes mankind's comparisons for
them. Now when you meet the unbeliever,
strike next until when you have subdued
them. Then make fast their bonds and
afterward either generosity or ransom
until the war lays down its burdens.
That and if Allah willed, he could have
punished them. But so that he may test
some of you by means of others. And
those who have been killed in the way of
Allah, he does not make their actions
useless. He will guide them and improve
their condition.
The literal understanding of this verse
is paramount among Islamic commentators.
Iban Cathir says that it means that when
Muslims fight against unbelievers, they
should cut them down totally with your
swords until you have killed and utterly
destroyed them. The taps align concurs
explaining strike the necks as meaning
kill them. Striking people's necks, he
explains generally results in their
death. I think he's got a point there.
The 20th century Quran translator
Abdullah Yusf Ali, although he has a
general habit of minimizing aspects of
the Quran that are jarring to Western
non-Muslims, he takes this literally as
well. And he justifies it by saying,
"You cannot wage war with kid gloves."
And that's fine. Many of the Muslims who
responded to me on X insisted that these
passages only had to do with wartime.
But when is that war waged? It does not
actually require a formal declaration of
war from a head of state. As long as
there are non-Muslims, Muhammad and
those who look to him as the perfect
example will believe that they have a
duty before Allah to fight them and
subjugate or kill them. As the passages
I've quoted now make clear. So does
Islam command Muslims to kill
non-Muslims? Most certainly. It's not
indiscriminate killing as the
non-Muslims can surrender and submit.
But no one who's honest can claim that
the Quran does not tell Muslims under
certain circumstances to kill
non-Muslims. And this warfare is
open-ended and will continue as long as
there are people whose religion is not
all for Allah.
The great medieval scholar Iben Caim in
the 14th century says it as he outlines
the stages of Muhammad's prophetic
career. For 13 years, he says, after the
beginning of his messengership, he
called people to Allah through preaching
without fighting or jiza, that's the tax
that those who submit pay, and was
commanded to restrain himself and to
practice patience and forbearance. Then
he was commanded to migrate and later
permission was given to fight. Then he
was commanded to fight those who fought
him and to restrain himself from those
who did not make war with him. And later
he was commanded to fight the
polytheists which is pretty much
everyone in the Islamic understanding
who is not an Islam not a Muslim.
Fight the polytheists until Allah's
religion was fully established. That
fight continues. And now you have the
context.